9h15 ce vendredi 16 septembre 2016
lorsqu'une explosion retentit au 15 de
la rue pierre palio à dijon derrière la
gare une explosion si violente qu'elle
est ressentie dans tout le quartier
l'immeuble de deux étages qui compte une
trentaine de studio essoufflé une
vingtaine de personnes et blessé ont
choqué ça fait comme une ex fine grosse
explosion et j'ai cru que tout allait
ses fins s'effondrer quoi et j'ai crié
j'ai appelé mon voisin il ya de la fumée
y avait de la fumée blanche et je suis
complètement traumatisé quoi jeu
j'ai eu très très peur quoi si on avait
été dans les parties derrière on était
mort franchement jusqu'à comme des gars
c'est terrifiant dans la journée
l'origine de l'explosion est connu il
s'agit d'une explosion au gaz causée par
un homme qui voulait se suicider suite à
une déception amoureuse
l'un des blessés sortis des décombres et
dont le pronostic vital est à l'heure où
nous parlons engagés à lever déclarer
spontanément à déclarer spontanément
sans apporter plus d'explications à son
geste qu'il était à l'origine de cette
explosion pour laquelle il avait utilisé
les bouteilles de gaz
cet individu dont je peux vous dire
qu'il est âgé d'environ une cinquantaine
d'années est connu des services de
police et des services de justice pour
avoir fait l'objet de condamnations dont
certaines sont anciennes
dans les jours qui suivent une
association d'aidé aux victimes via tôt
secours des habitants et des riverains
beaucoup sont choqués certains doivent
être relogées ou aider dans leurs
démarches administratives
l'objectif de cette permanence c'était
de faire en sorte que ces victimes ne se
sentent pas abandonner trop longtemps
l'immeuble quant à lui restera deux ans
l'état avant que sa démolition ne
commence en août 2010 8 sans qu'aucun
projet ne soit défini pour la suite
l'homme responsable de l'explosion est
jugé lui en juin 2019
devant les assises de côte-d'or pour
destruction volontaire par moyens
dangereux ayant entraîné des
interruptions temporaires de travail
il écope alors de 15 ans de réclusion